des vagues de place c'est que s'écrasent
sur la côte ouest du sri lanka
le navire qui brûle au large de la
capitale depuis dix jours transporté 28
conteneurs remplis de ces granulés de
polyéthylène mais d'entre eux sont déjà
tombés à l'eau
les débris de plastique se sont répandus
sur 80 km de côtes
les nettoyages est un travail de titan
qu'il faut recommencer à chaque nouvelle
marée la présence de ses billes dans les
eaux peu profondes pourrait nuire à la
biodiversité pendant des années geng he
is of america gagne la pollution
plastique augmente le contenu chimique
l'alcalinité l'acidité et la température
de l'eau les villages côtiers qui vivent
de pêche et le tourisme pourrait subir
d'importantes conséquences économiques
nous avons quatre mille cinq cents
familles de pêcheurs en fait la plupart
des villageois sont des pêcheurs donc la
population est très affecté par cette
tragédie des plans le prêtre du village
ce n'est pas le seul dommage que
pourrait causer ce porte-conteneurs 286
mètres de long puisqu'il transporte près
de 300 tonnes de mazout mais pour le
moment l'incendié semblait maîtrisé
selon le vice-amiral même si sa
structure demeure fragile
il n'y a pas de danger que le vaisseau
se brise et provoque une marée noire
les autorités du sri lanka ont ouvert
une enquête sur la façon dont le feu
s'est propagé et ont promis de
poursuivre en justice l'exploitant du
porte-conteneurs ici alexandre révélé le
radio canada montréal